une piste 100% féminine pour cette
journée dédiée
la ministre des sports était même au
rendez-vous pour promouvoir la pratique
des femmes que ce soit en compétition ou
en loisir objectif principal prendre du
plaisir
arrivé à parler plus de progrès plus de
plaisir que de sacrifices au nom de la
performance c'est notre objectif au
ministère des sports
aujourd'hui c'est important de dire
qu'aussi bien la performance des femmes
que celle des hommes méritent d'être
plus médiatisé plus mise à l'antenne
[Musique]
seuls 10% de ses licenciés sont des
femmes alors la fédération française de
cyclisme s'est saisie de cette opération
pour lancer son programme vivre vélo ou
féminin faut travailler sur ses points
faibles
ça fait deux ans et demi qu'on structure
vraiment notre taux de féminisation
qu'on commence à mettre en place à
pouvoir mettre en place des actions de
fond comme celle qu'on présente
aujourd'hui et j'espère que les fruits
de la croissance est bien on va les
trouver dans les prochaines années
pour cela la fédération a mis en place
un réseau d'ambassadrices dans toute la
france chargée d'organiser des
événements et d'encourager le cyclisme
féminin
je pense que les les femmes qui n'est
pas vraiment envie de faire du vélo
peut-être manque d'encadrement
ou de motivation d'être dans un groupe
de femmes donc voilà c'est à nous
maintenant de mettre en place des choses
à travers ce beau projet pour leur
donner envie de faire du vélo avec nous
dans la vallée heureuse
toute la journée les femmes étaient
invités à s'essayer au cyclisme sur
piste pour pourquoi pas s'inscrire en
club et faire progresser les chiffres
féminin